[Music]
Hogwarts will always be there to welcome
you home and so will these amazing Harry
Potter theories seriously you're not
ready to hear about Fred and George's
secret power don't forget to subscribe
to the things and give this video a
thumbs up if you love Harry Potter now
let's check out 10 Dark theories about
Harry Potter that will change everything
class size let's start with a few
theories that aren't known that well but
they actually seem pretty believable in
one of our interviews
JK Rowling said they're about a thousand
students at Hogwarts but have you ever
noticed that in the movie as well as in
the books
Harry's year is pretty small the movies
show about 18 students in Harry's year
and the books rarely mentioned anyone
else besides the people you already know
it doesn't add up if you think Hogwarts
supposed to have thousands of students a
tumblr user marauders forever came up
with the most amazing theory ever and
it's kind of sad - we know Voldemort was
at the reign of power between 1979 and
1981 which would have been the years
when Harry's class would be born there's
a connection between all those facts if
you think about it when Voldemort was at
the reign of power not a lot of people
survived and since he reigned during the
time when Harry's class would have been
born this tumblr user assumes that this
is exactly why his class was so small
it's a pretty dark theory but it
definitely would make sense right the
cursed job we all know that Defense
Against the Dark Arts was a cursed job
position but it was never really
explained why we also know that the
curse tried to be lifted by Albus
Dumbledore himself but he was unable to
a Reddit user has an interesting theory
on why that might be the case the curse
on the position started from the moment
Dumbledore refused the job - Voldemort
and we've also seen Voldemort
hide his diadem Horcrux in the room of
the requirement the entrance and the
exit of the room of the requirement
could be placed anywhere like we've seen
it in the last book where the students
avoid the Carrows this redditor thinks
that Voldemort's requirement when hiding
the diadem involved the defence against
the dark arts position to be cursed his
soul was anchored to one of the most
magical parts of the castle and acted as
a fuel for the curse the redditor also
adds that JK Rowling actually confirmed
that the curse
lifted following Voldemort's passing and
the destruction of the diadem so it's
safe to say there's definitely some
truth to the fact that Voldemort really
did try to make sure no other person
could become the Defense Against the
Dark Arts professor for too long the
Dursleys are innocent this is a popular
theory and there actually might be some
truth to it it also ties into
Voldemort's Horcruxes which as we
discovered changed how we see the story
completely but these theories change
them again so this popular fan theory
states that the Dursleys weren't
actually as mean as they seemed to be
let's remember that petunia was forced
to take harry in what's his parents
passed away but since Voldemort made
Harry an accidental Horcrux it means
that whoever's nearby him could
potentially feel the negative effects
Horcruxes have we saw this worked very
well and ugly Hallows but what if Harry
as a Horcrux had this effect on the
Dursleys what if they actually behaved
this way because of the Horcrux of
course this theory shouldn't excuse
abuse Harry endured in any way Daniel
Radcliffe actually shared his sentiments
on this theory and said that the
Dursleys would have been quite a
different family without Harry he did
say that he felt like the Dursleys just
really hated having Harry around but
that this is a pretty cool theory of
course petunias bitterness also came
from the fact that she never got to be a
witch like her sister so who knows if
things would actually change if Harry
wasn't a Horcrux
um bridges locket Umbridge is probably
one of the most hated characters in the
entire Harry Potter series Harry Potter
fans have a theory about the slytherins
locket which turned out to be one of
Voldemort's Horcruxes we told you the
entire Harry Potter story really changes
once you start theorizing on the
creation of the Horcruxes this theory is
similar to the theory about Dursleys but
it's still pretty interesting we all
know that Umbridge was wearing Salazar
Slytherin's locket and that she was
totally evil when she was do you see
where we're going with this so what if
the Horcrux had an extra effect on her
too when you combine it with the fact
that the defense against the dark arts
position was cursed because of another
Horcrux and the fact that Harry was
another one it can mean that umbrage was
just simply under the power of
too many Horcruxes JK rally actually
responded to these theories and stated
that while the Horcruxes would have
definitely added to her existing evil
demeanor umbrage was in fact evil on her
own to do be fair were kind of relieved
because the last thing we want to have
is sympathy for Dolores Umbridge
afterlife there are a couple of Harry
Potter theories out there about the
afterlife that actually seem pretty
believable
we'll discuss one more later on but
let's check out one right now one of
these theories focuses on Hedwig
everyone's favorite pet owl a redditor
stated that Hedwig could actually be
Lily Potter this reddit user states that
Hedwig always seemed extremely
protective of Harry and knew what was
happening at all times she was far too
intelligent and apathetic the redditor
also states that Hedwig would comfort
Harry even during the time he would stay
at the Dursleys the user also theorizes
that Lily Potter's Patronus would
definitely be a snowy owl do you see
where we're going with this another
editor also claimed that Hedwig's
passing came immediately after Harry's
seventeenth birthday which would be the
age when the protection spell from his
childhood would have worn off some even
state that Hedwig was actually a reverse
Horcrux and when Lily passed a part of
her soul became Hedwig although the last
theory makes less sense we can
definitely see how Lily's spirit could
live on in Hedwig after all she was
definitely the best had a person could
ask for wasn't she Snape's alive
Snape's entire character is a big fan
theory that actually came true if you
think about it he definitely had one of
the best Redemption stories ever some
fans seem to think that Snape is still
alive and they have a couple of points
to share a Reddit user came up with some
pretty impressive evidence to support
this theory and the first one comes from
the fact that Snape doesn't appear
during the summoning with the
resurrection stone Snape would have been
very important to Harry but yet he
didn't appear with the stone even if
Lupin did and another piece of evidence
states that Snape's body was nowhere to
be found after the Battle of Hogwarts
all other bodies were laid out on the
floor the snake's body wasn't there at
all and you'd think a skilled potions
professor could save himself from Nagini
Spang poison right Snape was the master
of
oceans but he couldn't find an antidote
he was a spy after all he seemed to have
a lot of trust in Nagini because we'd
definitely make sure she wouldn't be
able to attack us so could it be that
he's still alive after all or is that
just wishful thinking
Albus Dumbledore and Slytherin here's
another theory this one connects
Dumbledore to Salazar Slytherin and
while it might be one of the lesser
known theories it's definitely still
interesting some of this information
comes from fantastic beasts where you
can definitely learn some backstories on
a few characters we learn about assaults
a er a Slytherin descendant who had two
daughters that understood Parseltongue
and we all know Dumbledore seems to
understand Parseltongue perfectly well
and JK Rowling even implied that you
could only be born with the Parseltongue
knowledge there's no way anyone would be
able to just pick up Parseltongue and
learn it and we all know that Ron's
attempt was just pure luck so how is
Dumbledore able to understand
Parseltongue been and how does this
connect to Salazar Slytherin in Deathly
Hallows we learn a thing or two about
Dumbledore's mother Kendra including
that she looks like a Native American
this relates to the fact that assaults
Squibb daughter Martha actually married
a Native American man the theory states
that Kendra is actually related to
Martha as she seems to have Native
American features herself which also
means that Dumbledore is related to
assault Ser who's a Slytherin descendent
what do you think believable mechanicals
secret okay this next theory is pretty
dark actually it's by far one of the
darkest theories we're sharing today and
it will definitely change your
perspective on McGonagall she might be
everyone's favorite character but you
might change your mind after you hear
this story if there's one thing Harry
Potter fans want more than anything is
that Harry was never left with the
Dursleys
they were absolutely terrible but what's
even worse is the fact that McGonagall
knew this all along she even warned
Dumbledore and said they were the worst
type of muggles but it seems that she
never even wanted to check on Harry
after dropping him off Miss fig didn't
stop the abuse either by McGonagall had
to know what Harry went through since
his first Hogwarts letter was addressed
to the cupboard under the stairs
the letters changed based on Harry's
location so McGonagall must have had a
clear idea what Harry was going through
and yet she never wanted to intervene or
help fan theories state that she might
not be so innocent after all and the
truth is she really didn't want to help
Harry as much as she looked like she did
so much for being a motherly character
the truth about Crookshanks this is one
of our favorite fan theories and despite
the logical flaw which we'll mention in
a little bit it does seem the most
believable we have all met Crookshanks
but this furry cat also holds a lot of
mystery to it in fact there's not a lot
that's known about his origin van seemed
a state that Hermione wasn't the cat's
first owner considering she bought him
from a pet shop and the sales which said
that he's been there for ages and no one
wanted him we also know that the Potters
did actually have a cat because Harry
found his mother's letter in Deathly
Hallows the letter stated that Harry
almost hurt the cat while on his toy
broomstick and he even wondered what
happened to the cat so what if
Crookshanks actually belonged to the
Potters before Hermione got him maybe
someone found the cat and the magical
menagerie took him in after he was left
without his original owners seems pretty
believable right the one big flaw with
this theory is that Sirius would have
definitely known Crookshanks since he
was friends with the Potters he even
said that he had to gain the cat's trust
at some point but who knows maybe they
got Crookshanks after Sirius was sent to
Azkaban Fred and George switching bodies
one thing that's not explored enough in
Harry Potter are twins it seems strange
that twins wouldn't have any extra
powers or any other magical Inklings
right a theory states that Fred and
George were actually interchangeable and
could switch bodies whenever they wanted
Molly and Arthur even worried when Fred
and George weren't really doing any
accidental magic as kids but we all know
that could never be the case so what if
they were really switching bodies all
this time and no one even noticed the
theory states that Fred and George
learned to act like each other ever
since they were kids which is one of the
reasons why they can finish each other's
sentences they just know each other that
well from keeping their grades up to
keeping each other awake in class they
were switching bodies to help each other
in life soon their trick is discovered
by Lee
and later several other people that just
get to know them really well the theory
goes as far to state that this goes on
after Fred passes the to continue to
switch bodies until it's George's time
to join Fred at the Kings Cross station
a theory and a fanfiction who really
need this to happen and that's it for
the magical Harry Potter theories do you
believe any of those let us know in the
comments see you next time
[Music]